hey david with all of the talk of
vaccine passports i'm wondering
is a vaccine passport even really a
controversial thing
so no the answer is no i mean listen uh
the term vaccine passport is now being
used but what we're really talking about
is
to do certain things vaccination has
been required for a very long time
we're now talking about adding an
additional vaccination
but let's break it down to travel to
other countries
there have been vaccination requirements
for decades there are countries
in south america and in africa where you
need a yellow fever vaccine to go you
need to show proof
of yellow fever vaccination to go
to saudi arabia i don't know if it's at
any time or during the hajj
you need to show proof of a
meningococcal
vaccine there's a list just look at
mandatory
vaccine travel requirements so there's
really no
difference in another country saying
imagine france there's two things france
might do france could say everybody
who lives in france must be vaccinated
that would be government
forcing a vaccination on people that's
not going to happen
france could say to travel here from
another country
non-french anybody who's not who doesn't
have a citizenship
right to be in france we require the
covet 19 vaccine they could do that
that wouldn't be new that wouldn't be
controversial it would only be new as it
applies specifically to the coronavirus
vaccine
we are seeing more and more colleges say
to be on campus in the fall
students will have to be vaccinated this
is not new this is not controversial don
jr
has been tweeting about this as if it's
some kind of dystopian communist
authoritarian nightmare i know it makes
no sense his kids go to schools that
require
certain vaccinations and what some
schools are doing is they are
choosing what is the list of required
vaccinations to come to this school you
don't have to go to that school
now let's get to so now that we realize
that what we're talking about
is actually not new or particularly
controversial
let's go to what is being sometimes
implied by the term
vaccine passport um
one thing that's being implied is the
u.s government will require you to have
a vaccine it's not going to happen
it's just not going to happen and it's a
straw man this is sort of like when
someone says hey let's do universal
background checks
and the right says they're coming for
the second amendment they're going to
get rid of the second amendment no
that's not what's happening now what
happened not what's happening at all
there's not going to be mandatory us
government i can't speak for every other
country there may be some other
authoritarian countries
that will mandate covet vaccination the
u.s is not going to mandate covert
vaccination
what you what you may see is different
businesses
say we will require vaccination if you
want to do business with us
at a certain point you may see an
airline say we are beyond the period of
requiring a test
at this point if you want to fly with us
you need a vaccine
you may see um certain sports teams or
leagues
say if you want to come after a certain
date we're going to wait until the
vaccine has been open to everyone for
three months
after that point which would be i guess
july 19th
if you want to come to a game at our
stadium you need to be vaccinated
i don't think it will be super common
but that would be
completely within the rights of
businesses to
do and a lot of the right-wingers
opposing that are the same people that
for 20 years or 10 years or five years
have been saying businesses should be
able to do whatever they want as long as
it's not illegal it's not illegal to
require a vaccine
they will also there's another talking
point floating around which is
they are violating hipaa because they
are requiring you
to share medical information this is a
completely ridiculous interpretation of
what hipaa is hipaa is something that
medical professionals are bound by
the business isn't forcing you to reveal
first of all hipaa doesn't apply
because it's you not a doctor's office
that would be sharing vaccination
information number two
you're not even being required to do it
it's here is what
we require if you as a participant in
the market
choose to do business with us terrible
terrible argument
now are there arguments against vaccine
requirements generally this isn't just
about
covid uh sure sure um
you know if you have uh a situation
where there's really
inequitable access to a vaccine um
you could have a situation where what
you are saying is the poor
part of the world can't come to our
country
if we put in a vaccine mandate
and that's something that you could deal
with a friend imagine in the imaginary
france vaccine mandate
france might say uh to come to our
country if you're not a french national
of course
if you are in a country where
x percent of the population has already
been vaccinated then you need a vaccine
we will offer a test and quarantine
exemption
for people from countries that have not
yet reached 50
you could figure that out that's
something that you could figure out what
about people who can't get the vaccine
because of a condition that they have uh
where they are not able to get
vaccinated
okay that that's a now we're talking
about a practical issue that we can deal
with
can you get a medical exemption from a
vaccine requirement that's also not new
that's something that's been around for
a very long time
what countries can choose not to offer
though
are exemptions for so-called religious
beliefs and that would be up to
each each and every country to decide so
long story short
vaccine requirements for travel not new
vaccine requirements for
schools not new uh the government of the
u.s is not going to force people to be
vaccinated and beyond that we're talking
about people participating in markets
don't like
the rule that a business has don't do
business with them no problem whatsoever
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your
bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at
privacy.com pacman